quindi ho appena finito di guardare un video
entro il tempo della comunità ora chi sono davvero
come lei è così divertente e oh sì riguardo
alle paure emotive così come non
penso di avere mezzo um come le paure che
posso'  Spiegalo ma assicurati che ogni
volta che guardo un film dell'orrore ho passato l'
intera notte spaventato nel mio letto a
guardare come se sapessi che mi ha portato,
quindi è divertente perché non guardo mai
film dell'orrore da solo non potrei mai essere in
grado di farlo
ed è  divertente perché è nauseante brucia
sul divano e poi c'è come te albero
un mio amico è il suo prossimo dominio
e io mi comporto sempre come una specie di brillante
ehi
allora che ore sono questa cosa oh si
chiama l'esorcismo irrequieto e di
cosa parla  di non so di una
ragazza che è stata torturata nel sonno da
cose doppie come per favore sai il
tipo di film più spaventoso ora più oscuro
sai che hai paura
no ah chi l'hai preso prima sì ma
poi succede di solito si girano  spegnere le
luci che è qualcosa  g che odio
ed è come oh è come se avessimo davvero
bisogno di spegnere le luci
perché cosa vuoi che faccia ho tenuto
libero l'albero di Natale ma non so
come guardare un film con il figlio giusto
sì per via  vecchio Non penso che
sarebbe appropriato,
va bene e la cosa divertente,
ma dopo aver visto il film di solito
vado a letto e penso che potrei imparare il mio
letto per ore con gli occhi spalancati
Demming tutto intorno a me che di solito fa
qualcosa del genere  fissando la porta
e no mi aspetto sempre che
qualcosa salti fuori dall'angolo non so
guarda c'è il mostro del film che
aspetta che io mi abbia e poi tu
ti piaci inizi a interrogarti un
sacco di cose tipo perché  siamo qui perché
siamo qui
cosa ci faccio in questo mondo di
fantasmi davvero cosa ci faccio qui
perché me ne vado cosa posso anche vivere in
questo mondo e loro ne hanno bisogno a che serve
andarcene e poi morire dovrei
guarda quel film sì,
non vedrò più un film nel mio  tutta la vita
I film di mandorla oh Dio
Oh e se lei appare no ma va bene
non fissare la porta è la cosa peggiore
da fare no non farlo
bene quindi sì questi come
succede di solito e sì volevo solo
condividere i piselli